all is not well in new england for a
variety of reasons and we spent a lot of
time obsessing over the fact that the
patriots have lost two games in a row by
10 or more points for the first time
since 2002 and also this lingering bill
belichick tom brady feud or whatever it
is rob gronkowski continues to have
issues with the organization even though
we assume that once he declared a couple
of days before the draft that he's all
in for 2018 that everything was fine
remember he was thinking about
retirement right after the super bowl he
was asked any truth to the rumors that
you may retire and he said i don't know
how you heard about that which means
that the that to have heard about and he
didn't commit to playing in 2018 until
late april well he's got some lingering
frustrations his brother chris
gronkowski joined w-e-e-i on tuesday and
said some interesting things the first
clip from chris gronkowski now chris
gronkowski says he hasn't talked to rob
about this but knowing his brother and
watching his demeanor and his facial
expressions etc he knows that his
brother is frustrated with the offense
here's what chris gronkowski had to say
i could just tell by his emotions uh
his facial features and uh he's super
frustrated with it you'd see this at the
end of the game how the end of the game
double covered him pressing him off the
line and
you know he just wants to get the ball
in his hand and make plays but you just
can't do it when no one else is getting
open
is chris gronkowski one of the gronks
that played in new england wasn't there
another gronk that was like on the
practice squad at some point stats check
on that there was another garage
chris but i have the i i have i don't
know i have them all there's too many of
them i know there's too many of them
there is uh you know
first of all of course he's frustrated
and yes there's lack of weapons around
him uh that maybe help him out and matt
patricia gave new england a dose of
their own medicine and they basically
said we're gonna stop gronkowski and
let's see if somebody else can beat us
and they couldn't do that um
you know i i
i guess i you know when it comes to the
whole money thing too
you know about him wanting to be paid
like the the top tight end of football
well then you know damn why didn't you
hold out why like again you can't be a
part of the new england way and love all
the benefits of being in new england oh
we go to the super bowl and i get to
play with tom brady and we win all the
time we're on national tv
and then when it doesn't work out quite
the way you wanna you're frustrated at
the new england way you just can't have
it both ways i guess is what kind of
jumps out to me sometimes with this
well i think to a certain extent they
called his bluff right i think that's
what he was trying to do by being coy
about whether or not he was going to
actually
play in 2018 i think he was hoping they
would come to him on bended knee and say
rob what will it take financially to get
you to play and they didn't
and they actually were considering
trading him as recently as three days
before the draft they were calling
around the teams to see if they would
trade for gronk and you know the story
has been out there in various forms and
fashions it became one of the sunday
splash reports this weekend because the
lions and the patriots were playing each
other that the patriots were trying to
trade him to the lions and gronkowski
said no i don't want to be traded to the
lions and that's what forced him to
renew his vows with the patriots so the
patriots played this right because to
the extent gronk was i mean you know
he's not wired to hold out he stayed
away from the voluntary offseason
program but he's not wired to hold out
he wasn't wired to retire and he
ultimately took the deal that the
patriots gave him which is incentive
laden and the problem is if you aren't
catching passes you aren't going to earn
that money and that's why he's got to be
frustrated and look you're right though
chris
if you want to maximize your earning
potential you have to be willing to use
your leverage and gronkowski wasn't
willing to say i'm holding out and i
think he must have sensed if he got into
a stare down with bill belichick he was
going to lose yeah i i think so too and
maybe the fact that he just did i don't
know what it is he didn't want to be the
public enemy he certainly didn't want to
get traded and start back at square one
but yeah i mean
i do believe especially this year he had
the leverage with the edelman suspension
when when that news came out he should
have just been like huh
oh oh good luck i won't be there until i
get paid like the top tight end of
football that's what he should have done
i mean the fact that guys like jordan
reed travis kelsey and jimmy graham are
making more money than rob gronkowski
that's a joke but gronkowski has nobody
to blame but himself in this so that's
where i come back to and just go well i
mean okay you're sacrificing being the
top high pays guy because yeah you're
probably going to be in the final four
or maybe in the super bowl this year
and for more on the concerns about his
contract here's another clip from chris
gronkowski appearing tuesday morning on
weei
it was kind of a crazy off-season and
it wasn't a ton of communication between
the two but yeah he wanted to get paid
what what he deserved and he wanted to
be paid you know
one of the top tight ends for once
it's been uh it's been a struggle for
him to make that money he knows what he
needs to get done so
he just wanted some more freedom and he
wanted to get what he deserved him and
he was being paid like he was just a
mediocre tight end and just wanted to
get some respect on that front as well
and that's exactly what you're saying
chris but the problem is look if you're
under contract and you don't like your
contract you have to be willing to stay
away and i think this is a combination
of two things first of all the patriots
are never going to let their knees get
wobbly if a player would stand up to
them like that and secondly tom brady's
making less than he deserves if it's
good enough for tommy it's good enough
for you gronk and that's just the way it
is so ultimately he gets that that same
kind of deal that he got last year the
same kind of package that tom brady got
the incentive laden extra money where
you've got to earn it before you get it
and i think gronk is going to have a
much harder time getting it this year
than last year and that only adds to the
frustration and here's what it also adds
to i mean think about because brady and
gronk both have these incentive packages
and maybe they don't earn a penny of it
based upon the way things have gone so
far offensively doesn't that add to this
notion that after this year the the
divorces are coming
i mean it doesn't look pretty right now
certainly i'm not going to go that far i
think the other thing that i think you
know
that means needs to be a disgust a
little i mean i have a hard time
thinking that tom brady's not paid
through other some shell company by the
kraft family i mean i feel like that's
kind of one of those things that's
around nfl conversation no no no wait do
you have evidence or are you just gonna
i'm just recklessly speculating i'm i'm
i'm kind of speculating within
rumorville of the nfl i do not have
evidence of that you have no evidence
whatsoever you're not making that
allegation all right i'm not making that
i have not yet heard from nbc legal i
don't need to i know that you're on
dangerous ground when you start throwing
out this suggestion that he's being paid
extra money through shell companies you
don't even know what a shell company is
and and that there's somehow some extra
compensation that it'd be a blatant
violation of the labor deal yeah i mean
i don't think and here's the thing i
don't think it's the first time it's
gone on in the nfl so i'm not sitting
here trying to blame them for that it's
just something that i i think about at
times yes
well and and and look it's it's amazing
to me that for all of the the times
where the patriots have been accused of
and and caught doing things that maybe
they shouldn't be doing and really the
only one that i think is provable is
spygate i think deflategate was all
overblown and at best the evidence was
inconclusive but it is amazing to me
that there haven't been more people who
have recklessly speculated like you have
and are that there's some other
channel of of revenue where brady's
getting compensated by
the the patriots in a way that doesn't
affect the salary cap although there is
no evidence of that there is no evidence
of that speculating but i'm also saying
you've heard those speculation rumors i
think as well i mean this is not
something that you know doesn't go
talked about in the nfl that's all i was
trying then why can't they do it for
gronk why don't they have some shell
companies forever exactly where i was
going that's why i was trying to say
like you know gronk i don't think you're
getting all those benefits that maybe
brady is getting from from the the new
england patriots either way but hey i
understand his frustrations and his
brother did a great job
of saying that rob didn't really say
this and i can just read his facial
expressions but damn i just it seems
kind of weird that w-e-e-i called the
guy that's just going i don't really
know i'm just reading facial expressions
i think that he he's had these
conversations with rob and w-e-i knows
he's had these conversations with rob
and he just made it sound like he did
not have these conversations with rob
and he can just tell because he's a
brother and he knows all those kind of
things i'm just speculating on that as
well no no now here's the thing
it's one thing to have not talked to him
about his frustrations currently in the
offense and to be gleaning how he feels
from watching the games on tv but as it
relates to the frustrations in the
offseason with his contract he had no
such caveat right right he he spoke with
authority that there was disappointment
that the contract wasn't taken care of
that he's not being paid what he
deserves and ultimately i mean i need to
look at the numbers and it's still too
small of a sample size but he may have
some some catching up to do a lot of
catching up to do to get on the pace
necessary to to get to the catches
receiving yards touchdowns that he needs
in order to unlock the incentive package
that they gave him for this year and i
really thought that this year that they
would just give him more base pay
because if you get injured at some point
that's it you're done it's over look
what richard sherman's dealing with he's
going to lose over 4 million dollars
because he signed that deal with the
49ers that ties so much of his pay to 90
playing time to pro bowl all pro per
game roster bonuses you missed three or
four games with a calf injury goodbye to
four and a half million dollars yeah and
i think the truly great players in the
nfl should ensure that they get paid
whether they're injured or not and that
does screw up a team salary cap but
jimmy garoppolo is getting his money
even though he's not going to play
another game this year he's going to
lose some pro game roster bonuses but
he's still getting the bulk of his cash
and and i think that uh you know for a
guy like gronkowski who's had a series
of injuries throughout his career that's
right an incentive package for two
straight years not a good idea no yeah
the numbers show that he won't make it
through the year right i mean if we just
went through what you know history and
his injury bug so yeah i'm with you i
think that's where like i get surprised
that he uh accepts these incentive
packages for the second year in a row
because man if anybody knows you can be
out for the season it's rob gronkowski i
mean it's been elbows knees backs
whatever it is i mean he has been he's
sam do you know who cavity sam is i do
not
this is the second reference you're
bringing up before it was charlie liver
guy and now who the hell it was it was
carter's liver pills right cavity sam is
the guy who is the patient in the
operation game oh that's cavity sam okay
that's cavity i did not know that yes
that game was invented in 1964
but it is still sold today it is still
one of the few board games you're the
guy stats who has board game parties
every saturday night and plays monopoly
and parcheesi and trouble and what else
what other board games were there life i
bet you loved playing the game of life
life's pretty good damn so that's what
you do on saturday night stats game
night is a fun night i'm sorry i have
friends you don't that's
you're probably i haven't seen no proof
of friends and we don't count as friends
right oh you don't
i just asked that's what you do on a
saturday night and he just took a shot
at me and said it's fun and i have no
friends you mean to say that to mike and
not me please tell me that
okay
the hell with you i don't wanna ever go
to your board game night anyways kristin
i don't wanna hear what you do on
saturday night you can tell me off the
air
you